fully autonomous flight may seem easy  you don't need to stick to roads and  have much more space to maneuver and  avoid obstacles  but detecting other aircraft can be hard  even in the us ninety percent of low  altitude flights don't require  transponders that would allow drones to  detect other aircraft  drones need cheap and low weight sensors  that can see through fog and clouds with  360 degrees of spherical sight  zipline had a batty idea to do this with  cheap off-the-shelf sensors microphones  zipline has created a reliable system  that can pinpoint aircraft locations in  3d space using these eight microphones  using signal processing algorithms  allowing their drones to automatically  detect and avoid aircraft bringing us  one step closer to safe drone  integration in our airspace